all right you guys may have seen this
video by now former president trump
going viral filmed teeing up at a golf
course in california and he teased his
2024 presidential run take a look
i'll be lucky we'll be lucky we're up
first on t
45th president of the united states 45th
and 47th 47th yes and i love that mr
trump ladies and gentlemen
big t-box energy there from the former
president the current commander-in-chief
struggling doing a little better today
but this was yesterday struggling to
string a sentence together
but uh
um might point out you're uh
when i went to dearborn driving that
uh you know uh was up there i don't know
man
all right let's welcome in now host of
the reuben report dave rubin his next
book don't burn this country comes out
in april it gets closer every single
week we promote it dave great to have
you with us
john before we get going here and talk
about trump i just want to say in light
of your previous segment i just want to
thank you and all the newsmax people for
having me on despite being a white man i
know i am not a black woman joe biden is
only going to choose a black woman and i
just want to thank you john bachman for
still considering me to be a guest on
this show so thank you very much for
that i appreciate it we want the guests
on this show to look like the country
dave it needs to you know diverse cast
of characters
but which one of those two men would you
feel more comfortable making a lifetime
appointment
uh the biden thing is it's boring
because it's depressing and no one
really wants to see what we all see the
president of the united states is the
guy that's the pilot of the plane that
we're all in and you want the pilot to
be qualified you want the pilot to have
his mental wherewithal and to know what
he's doing and it's just very obvious
that this thing is breaking down more
and more every single day and they're
they're losing the ability to control it
right too many of these videos leak out
all the time too many of these press
conferences end where he says ooh i'm
not supposed to ask questions they don't
want me to talk or he stammers etc etc
uh that being said you know trump he
made an interesting comment there okay
he was 45 we get it biden's 46 he wants
to be 47 well trump has to answer one
big
question uh before he could get support
from someone like me who did support him
last time uh which is that if you truly
believe that there were shenanigans in
the election last time well then what
have you done or what are your people
doing to ensure that that wouldn't
happen again if that is what you believe
then how could you run again if nothing
has been done to address that i mean
that seems like the real elephant in the
room here so we'll see what happens with
the republicans but that that really is
the only issue if that's what he
believes again that's separate from what
either happened or didn't have it but if
that is his belief which is what we've
been told it is
what are you going to do so i think he
has to address that and then i think
things can shake out a little bit more
you bring that update but i have this
conversation with so many people offline
they don't want it to be on the news but
they say look you know talking about
2020 is one thing but you know this
election integrity issue is is so
important for the future in future
elections and they want to know what
donald trump is doing to make sure
because so many people are working on
that issue he's talked about it they
want to they want to know like you know
or once by the way john let me let me
just say one other thing on this which
is that you know biden is so weak at
this point and and the approval ratings
prove that and the you know all the
problems we're having between the supply
chain and inflation and everything else
that in some ways trump running you know
that's going to energize the left base
which is very depressed at the moment
right those there's very few people
right now that are going boy this biden
guy is great knows what he's doing
things are going well this is really
fantastic there's almost no one saying
that even even the hardcore democrats
but you would you would inflame those
people by having trump run i'm not
saying trump shouldn't run right like we
still don't know where things are at you
know i'm here in florida now i love ron
desantis i'd like to keep him here in
florida we shall i want to talk about
desantis yeah okay all right let's get
to it but i wanted to ask you too i want
to stick on the supreme court thing i
just you know president biden's
obviously going to nominate a liberal
here we just hope it's not somebody uh
who gets all their facts from npr like
sonia sotomayor remember this during the
covet stuff last week or a couple weeks
ago here she is
we have hospitals that are almost at
full capacity with people is severely
ill on ventilators we have over a
hundred thousand children which we've
never had before in in serious condition
and uh many on ventilators
you know bill bill maher this past
weekend called sonia sotomayor
incredibly uh i don't know what he said
but ignorant i guess about about the
facts at hand and
bill maher man
and bill they are they'll be the biggest
thing on my show i did a big thing on my
show about it this week it's like bill
maher you get it now you're really
starting to get it bill maher but you
got to start voting the right way too
that's a secondary issue here as for
what sotomayor said there i mean no
there aren't a hundred thousand children
on ventilators in serious condition uh
you know we've constantly been told for
two years about these overrun hospitals
can i see any video of it from how about
not even in america how about somewhere
in africa show me a overrun hospital
show me all the dead bodies in the
hallways and everything else again
that's not to diminish covet okay john
you know i had it a couple weeks ago i'm
okay i had some leg pains got monoclonal
treatment here in florida which now the
federal government is cutting off by the
way that's our next topic of convo but
but exactly what they've done here is
really dishonest because they constantly
are flagging us for misinformation and
yet you've got a supreme court justice
of the united states in an incredibly
important hearing and by the way that
wasn't the only bit of misinformation
that she leaked a hundred thousand kids
on ventilators no no it's not true
they've politicized covet they've
politicized the supreme court you know
and we have this issue where ron
desantis is going back and forth with
the white house about these monoclonal
antibody treatments the white house says
they're not effective
uh i think you would you could speak
to the other side of that right
look i can tell you what happened to me
and of course this is just one person
saying what happened to them but there's
a lot of other people like me i got
covered a little bit before christmas
when it was really running wild i got
monoclonal treatment i had just moved
here to florida got monoclonal treatment
within about two hours and i had about
three days of leg pains and a sore
throat i'm not vast that was my own
personal choice
and i believe in personal choice i don't
believe in mandates
there's an awful lot of evidence that
monoclonal treatments work by the way
there's some questions whether it really
works toward with omicron which is the
variant that's running around right now
but we should be allowed to talk about
that but the simple point the simple
fact of this is that the reason that the
federal government is now holding this
stuff back is because they know it was
working in places like florida where if
you had symptoms you could go get
monoclonal treatment at a public
facility which were all over the state
where in california which as you know i
fled it was very hard to get mono clonal
treatment you had to have a positive
test but it was very hard to get a test
in the first place because there was a
testing shortage so we seem to punish
places states in this case for doing
things right and and that's why we've
got to fight these guys at every level
whatsoever uh we do and you know if if
the monoclonal antibody treatments
aren't uh effective against omicron what
are we supposed to take away from the
vaccines obviously uh they're not
stopping the spread either oh john
you're trying to get us kicked off
maybe
we'll have to keep this one on rumble
dave this one can only go on rumble uh
today and also uh mark halperin i want
to get your take on this real quick we
only got a couple seconds here but mark
halperin is telling us that dr fauci's
days could be numbered he says dr fauci
has been seen by most veteran biden
watchers as untouchable and unfireable
that has not been joe biden's style but
now some democrats close to the
president wonder if fauci is or at least
should be on the chopping block what do
you think dave
somebody's got to go right two years
into this thing 15 days to flatten the
curb fire somebody fire the janitor at
the nih fire the electrician at the cdc
somebody's got to go i would start
without you all right dr fauci you are
on notice great to see you dave sorry
tony i'm glad to hear you're feeling
better too
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell